[Musique]
un 100 m en jean et ça c'est le caméra
mal c'est complètement dingue c'est
pourquoi parce qu'il va plus vite que
les sprinteurs voilà alors du coup aux
idées qui va gagner 100 m et bien c'est
lui c'est le caméraman c'est une course
locale
je ne sais pas mais c'est un truc de
dingue en tout cas mais oui mais oui tu
roules or cameramen en film parce que
franchement pas que les français ont
pris deux kilos en moyenne avec le
confinement
c'est ce que ça vous inspire comme
réflexion que vous voulez pas vous mais
les fans de sport ceci dit ceci je suis
comme tout le monde je suis exactement
comme toulouse va falloir s'y remettre
un petit peu avant avant cet été
je vais vous nourrir jusqu'à en
explosifs le patron s'appelle jon basso
un mec ce nutritionniste reconverti dans
la malbouffe version provoque alors pour
toi tu vas prendre en de rigueur et en
dessert il te faut la crème fouettée au
beurre goût fraise
[Applaudissements]
nous on dit la vérité à nos clients
notre cuisine vabre ou tout simplement
entre lâche 2,6 en un tiers des enfants
prennent tous leurs repas devant la
télévision
un temps d'écran qui se multiplient par
deux jusqu'à atteindre une heure vingt
par jour en moyenne avec des
conséquences importantes sur leur
développement
ces enfants perdent trois à cinq points
de cui par rapport aux autres
une différence qui s'explique par le
manque de discussion avec leurs parents
primordial dans les premières années il
faudrait qu'on parle plus globalement de
la question du des programmes télé qui
sont de plus en plus tard je trouve que
pour les enfants c'est terrible ils
peuvent absolument plus jamais regarder
la télé en semaine c'est peut-être très
bien pour tous les profs kinect outre 8
mes enfants après tout pourquoi se
préoccuper de l'éducation de nos enfants
quand on peut s'offrir une lampe
connectés qui promet de le faire à notre
place allons voir quel génie se cache
derrière cette sorte de lampe magique
qui a conquis le marché chinois
c'est une épidémie aujourd'hui dans ce
pays les enfants restent assis
concentrer sur leurs études ils
oubliaient le dehors on laisse plus les
enfants être les enfants
en cause l'utilisation excessive des
écrans ces derniers mois grandeur passée
son temps libre devant son téléphone
en deux ans il a pris plus de 10 kg et
souffre même d'hypertension c'est un
objet connecté avec deux caméras alors
la première elle filme l'enfant de fat
voilà on peut la voir et il ya une autre
caméra qui surplombe toute la pièce du
bureau qui peut à la fois analysé des
écritures sur le cahier comme tous les
mouvements qui peut y avoir autour de la
pièce
évidemment cet objet dispose d'un
assistant vocal 24 heures sur 24
ah oui elles ou leurs dhabi j'ai parfois
l'assistant vocal peut-être méchant si
jamais ils battront ils donnent les
mauvais points
elle ce qu'elle veut c'est être la
première est écrasé toutes les autres
jeunes
mignon mais attention si l'enfant si le
bambin comme vous diriez elizabeth est
un peu fatigués et met sa tête comme ça
au creux de son bras ou succomba et
toutes autres quads et snacks et oui
c'est courant un geste à l'hôtel un
mouchard la lampe averti les parents qui
depuis leur smartphone peuvent voir que
leurs enfants ne font pas vraiment leur
devoir et l'interpellent directement sur
l'objet ni comment il s'appelle temps
d'attendre qu'elle s'appelle le cerveau
de la rega
et pourquoi tu as fait ton cerveau parce
que j'aime bien et c'est toujours rêvé
depuis que je suis petit d'être
neurochirurgienne s'est toujours voulu
être kocher les gauchers sont pointés
chaque fois qu'il arrive derrière il ya
aussi beaucoup de boulot parce que c'est
pendant la journée on bosse énormément
pour se préparer à aller dans l'espace
on bosse énormément baissé comme vous tu
sais y'a pas que le soulevé les trophées
et puis est passé à la télé je sais que
dans la vie tout est joué énormément de
boulot de la femme du joueur pro c'est
souvent collé à l'image de la femme qui
dépensent les millions de son mari qui
font rien qui est que dans l'espace et
dans les magasins et je vais vous
montrer que vous vous trompez je suis
pas qu'un physique
moi j'en ai là dedans on sent
directement que je le pense
vous dites que vous ne croyez pas
supériorité des quéquette mais pour
autant je ne vous répondrai pas
féministe vous méfier des 9-10 féministe
alors denis baupin lui illustré cette
réticence
oui cette circonspection je pense pas
que ce soit le rôle d'un mec d'être
féminisme alors marie paule pourquoi la
sirène
parce que c'est un homme aurait donc une
femme
ah ouais on n'avait pas fait le
rapprochement fabia qui compte 70 je me
laisse glisser en vrai moi je viens de
mettre des implants dans mes fesses et
ses graffs fragile parce que j'ai très
peur de tomber sur les fesses et que ça
se déplace du coup là je me dis faut que
j'y aille mollo parce que j'ai pas envie
de repasser sous billard je pense que le
féminisme c'est une c'est une éthique
est une chose trop riche et trop
complexe pour qu'on sente affuble
assurément magic pitot c'est le nom de
ces petite confiserie ces petits bonbons
imaginé par une militante féministe
celle ci est partie d'un constat il est
très simple de trouver en quelques clics
sur internet des bonbons en forme de
pénis
il ya du choix toutes les couleurs
toutes les tailles en revanche aucune
représentation du clitoris au rayon
bonbons et c'est donc pour rétablir
cette forme d'égalité qu'elle a imaginé
ces petits bonbons clitoris
elle est gourmande et invités coûteuse
la tonne ecoutez-la l'air elle sera
progressive selon des chiffres très
sérieux de l'ifop
un quart des françaises ont déjà été
biffle et et ceux dont une autre enquête
de l'ifop
cette griffe les hautement politique on
sait par exemple qu'il est plus pratiqué
par les électeurs du rassemblement
national
en revanche les civils ce beef le plus
le vide
les électrices ce billet les autres
[Musique]
un rocker jamie ajouté m
hop hop hop crise qui ce pack vous
croyez je peux jouer un rôle de père
mais juste on n'a rien fait nous quelle
image les arabes on donne et vous nous
amenez un très joli miroir miroir line
vautrin
trouvé dans un vide maison il ya trois
ans la banque mondiale waouh pour 150
euros
non
non vraiment ouais vraiment il n'y a
dans la voix la lumière il ya le fils de
l'existence il y a quelque chose d'à la
fois rémanents et fugace émanant fugace
et y'a pas à dire des mots comme ça
127 milles euros rendez vous compte une
somme absolument incroyable pour ce
miroir jean vautrin j'abdique aller
allez-y c'est bon
merci
[Musique]
bravo bravo qua non
l'anglais jamie foxx ou là